get into today's stories you guys area
15 has been
a great source of a lot of fun here in
las vegas the entertainment complex just
opened up some new experiences and
rocky's taking a swing at them
here is her first stop yeah in true area
15 fashion we have figured out how to
make
an art installation out of golf clubs
okay we are at five iron golf
new to area 15. why did you guys bring
it here uh we wanted to
uh be a part of this obviously really
cool
place we have eight full simulators here
you can come and hit balls
have fun enjoy yourself now of course
golf but i also see a full bar what else
can we enjoy
awesome yeah we have a full bar right
behind us um as well as
food provided by todd english uh the
beast nice so
i feel like this is safe we're golfing
in our cubicles here we've got social
distancing yeah everything's six feet
apart
we clean the clubs and the balls after
every use want to make sure safety is
our first priority
good to know okay the last thing here i
feel like i gotta get on the green is
that the right terminology
getting on the greens right the right
way so i'm gonna walk you over all right
i'm gonna introduce you to our pro
shawn and he's gonna get you going all
right coach i'm passing the mic on to
you you give me the club
you have the harder job i do you're
right all right how's my form it's not
too bad let's take a swing and we'll
tell you what we can do with it whoa not
too bad
some of the technology that we utilize
we have instant video feedback oh this
is great
we have dozens of data points that talk
about ball speed which clubhead's doing
and a number of other things which we
also use for club fitting
and for avid practicers they can come
get all their numbers
we can send it to them that's great can
i can i print this out here
absolutely you can we can send it to you
we can email it to you have it all right
at your fingertips oh that is so cool so
i feel like obviously this is so much
fun but also
you can get some real practice in for
the pros right definitely as serious as
you want to be
okay well five iron golf this is going
to be my new favorite place but coming
up later in the show
we've got an arcade bar that sounds fun
too without a doubt
all right we'll see you later hey that
was a legit swing
everything rocky does she's like pro
right seriously i mean she's an athlete
so
but man that was good we will see rocky
later in the show all right